hey everyone this is ben with
registerednessrn.com
and in this video i'm going to
demonstrate supination
and pronation which are special
movements involving rotation
of the forearm your forearm consists of
two bones you have the
radius which is on the lateral side of
the forearm in the anatomical position
and you also have the ulna which is on
the medial side in the anatomical
position
during supination the distal end of
the radial bone is going to rotate
around the ulna
in a lateral direction now lateral
rotation is away from the body's midline
so this motion is going to look like
this and i like to pay attention to the
thumbs because the thumb is on the same
side as the radius hence when you check
a radial pulse
you're checking just below the thumb
right here so when you look at the
thumbs and if you imagine there's a
midline going down my body
like kind of in line with my necktie
watch the thumbs and as it's rotating
away from the midline of the body
this is supination in contrast pronation
is the opposite movement
here we're going to see the distal end
of the radial bone
rotate over the ulna in a medial
direction
so medial means towards the midline of
the body so now we're going to see those
thumbs point
towards the body's midline some people
also like to look at the orientation of
the palms of the hand to help them
determine
whether supination or pronation is
occurring so if i put my arms down like
this and you look at the palms of my
hands
supination is going to result in that
lateral rotation of the radial bone
which is going to leave your palms
facing forward or anteriorly
and this might look familiar because
this is exactly their orientation in the
anatomical position
however if my elbow were flexed about 90
degrees
now what's happened the palms are facing
up in contrast pronation is going to
have the palms facing the opposite
direction
they are going to face posteriorly or
toward the back in the anatomical
position
or if my elbow reflects about 90 degrees
then pronation is going to have the
palms facing
down or inferiorly now let me give you a
really simple mnemonic to help you
remember these two movements
you see this girl right here at the
store she has to pronate
to pick up her produce so you have to
pronate to pick up your produce
and when you want to eat it for supper
you supinate and bring it to your mouth
or if you want to take a multivitamin
you have to pronate to poor
and you have to supinate to catch the
supplement okay that wraps up this video
over
supination and pronation which again are
special body movements that you will
learn in
anatomy we have a free quiz that you can
take on our website just click the link
in the description below
we also have a whole playlist of anatomy
videos that you might find helpful so
check those out
thank you so much for watching and
please subscribe